in one day I was lowering the views and
living an adventurer and the track knew
flying a client fell on his face yes
because I did not have time to yell at the
client
[Music]
I am manta 1 the most day and I have scored
the most today
2 to wáyar
at the beginning we took it down the stairs,
so with the pizza walking we
got very tired and people
gave us and ideas and the idea arose of with
a sixth lower the pencil by the balcony
maxwell don't wait for the opinion of peter and
alive  the turn is called my way
because you ask for the track in your
own way and we feel like
pixar and a lot of pressure martin and bones
grup scout like exporters and crespi on the
first visit in the dough and in the sauce
and each mystery has  their recipe
headers of their sauce their way they don't
tell their secret
that we have tried to keep the
same type of dough here the dough is
manual
[Music]
the quality of the pieces
is unquestionably good here come
people from the beach of the municipality  No one goes to the beach
to buy pizza, it helps Cubans
because it helps people survive and
quality
[Music]
of anything
to decide
the business I always try to do
things laughing and laughing ourselves
because because it's laughter that makes your
day  and the smile has tremendous value
[Music]